So, we just covered six different
caching strategies that you can use.
Cache first then network, network first
then cache, cache only, network only,
though I guess technically that's
not really cache and strategy, oops.
Cache and network race, and
finally cache then network.
It's important to choose the right
strategy for the right kind of data.
And don't be afraid to experiment or
even combine the different strategies.
If there are parts of your
app that you can't cache for
some reason, give the users
something fun to do in the meantime.
For example,
the Guardian newspaper in the UK
gives users a crossword puzzle
to play while they're offline.
If you want to dive deeper into
ways that you can cache content,
check out the offline cookbook linked
in the instructor notes below.
Or check out Jake Archibald's
offline web applications course.